J'ai vraiment bousculé pour cette
[ __ ] de merde, ce spectacle ne m'a pas été
donné [ __ ]
[Musique]
ma mère m'a bien élevé j'ai choisi de mal faire
mon rêve a toujours été d'être un rappeur,
mais je devais trouver un travail  donc j'ai dû me
concentrer sur mon travail
[Musique]
Je me suis vu à cet âge J'ai 25 ans Je
dois avoir cette somme d'argent pour pouvoir
quitter le jeu ouvrir quelques affaires pour que
je puisse être bon et avoir [ __ ]  enfants
[Musique]
et regardez, j'ai arrêté de danser le premier jour où
j'ai eu 23 ans et il m'avait mis assez et
m'a assez béni pour non seulement
investir dans des objectifs réalistes mais dans mes
rêves qui sont la musique
[Musique
] c'était comme vous le savez quand le  première fois que
tu vois comme le gars que tu aimes le pénis
et comme moi mon dieu
c'est comme ça que j'ai l'impression que je ne peux pas parler je
ne peux pas respirer
[Musique]
J'ai été à tant de choses et
c'est comme si ce n'était pas  si difficile pour moi d'être
ici et c'est comme si j'étais enfin là pour
obtenir ce que je voulais le respect des
autres artistes et de tous ceux que j'ai
vus  beaucoup de fusillades à l'école se produisent
et ce n'est jamais comme si l'école
n'avait jamais ressemblé au jock
la pom-pom girl l'enfant populaire c'est
toujours comme un enfant qui a l'air un
peu maladroit socialement et tout
et c'est comme si je me sentais comme l'un des  la meilleure
façon d'éviter ce type de tragédies
est d'arrêter de s'en prendre à ces enfants
[Musique]
cette merde est vraiment sérieuse [ __ ] de frère
cette merde est folle comme si notre pays était
dans un enfer en ce moment tout pour un [ __ ] de
mur
j'ai vraiment besoin de prendre ça au sérieux je
sentir que nous devons agir
[Musique]